FAILING.
THAT IS THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT’S
VERY SAD ANGLE.
TO ME WHAT WAS MOST SURPRISING
ABOUT THE DEMOCRAT DEBATE RIGHT
NOW WASN’T THAT ELIZABETH WARREN
CAME OUT PUNCHING AGAINST
MICHAEL BLOOMBERG BUT HOW
UNPREPARED HE SEEMED FROM THE
GET-GO.
>> I WOULD LIKE TO TALK ABOUT
WHO WE ARE RUNNING AGAINST.
A BILLIONAIRE WHO CALLS WOMEN
FAT BROADS AND HORSE FACED
LESBIANS.
AND NO, I’M NOT TALKING ABOUT
DONALD TRUMP.
I’M TALKING ABOUT
MAYOR BLOOMBERG.
>> Laura: HIS INSTINCT WAS TO
IGNORE ELIZABETH WARREN, SPEAK
IN GENERAL TERMS AND WHEN ALL
ELSE FAILS, JUST RECITE HIS
RESUME.
>> I’M A NEW YORKER, I KNOW HOW
TO TAKE ON AN ARROGANT CON MAN
LIKE DONALD TRUMP THAT COMES
FROM NEW YORK.
I AM A MAYOR.
I WAS A MAYOR.
I KNOW HOW TO RUN A COMPLICATED
CITY.
THE BIGGEST, MOST OF DIVERSE CIT
IN THE COUNTRY.
>> Laura: WARREN WAS CIRCLING
HIM LIKE A TURKEY VULTURE OVER A
WOUNDED FAUN.
>> HE HAS GOTTEN SOME NUMBER OF
WOMEN, DOZENS, WHO KNOWS, TO
SIGN NONDISCLOSURE AGREEMENTS
FOR SEXUAL HARASSMENT AND FOR
GENDER DISCRIMINATION IN THE
WORKPLACE.
SO, MR. MAYOR, ARE YOU WILLING
TO RELEASE ALL OF THOSE WOMEN
FROM THOSE NONDISCLOSURE
AGREEMENTS?
SO WE CAN HEAR THEIR SIDE OF THE
STORY?
[APPLAUSE]
>> Laura: YOU WOULD THINK WITH
ALL THAT DUO HE SHELLED OUT,
THAT BLOOMBERG WOULD BE READY
FOR THOSE OBVIOUS POINTS
SHE WAS GOING TO RAISE, RIGHT?
WELL.
>> NONE OF THEM ACCUSED ME OF
DOING ANYTHING OTHER THAN MAYBE
THEY DIDN’T LIKE A JOKE.
>> AND WHEN YOU SAY THEY SIGNED
THEM, IF THEY WISH NOW TO SPEAK
OUT AND TELL THEIR SIDE OF THE
STORY, ABOUT WHAT IT IS THEY
ALLEGE, THAT IS NOW OKAY WITH
YOU?
>> THEY WANTED TO KEEP IT QUIET
FOR EVERYBODY’S INTERESTS.
>> WOMEN WERE BEING MUZZLED BY
YOU.
>> THEY WERE MADE CONSENSUALLY
AND THEY HAVE EVERY RIGHT TO
EXPECT THAT THEY WILL STAY
PRIVATE.
[AUDIENCE BOOING]
>> Laura: OH, BOY,.
ZERO EMOTION.
ZERO CONNECTION AND IN THE END,
ZERO CREDIBILITY.
ONSTAGE, HE HAS NEITHER THE RAW
POLITICAL SKILL OR THE RAW
INSTINCT OF TRUMP, OR BERNIE FOR
THAT MATTER.
NOW BERNIE, I HAVE TO GIVE HIM
CREDIT.
HE KNOWS HIS BASE AND HIS BASE
WANTS MASSIVE WEALTH
REDISTRIBUTION.
>> WE HAVE A GROTESQUE AND
IMMORAL DISTRIBUTION OF WEALTH.
MICHAEL BLOOMBERG OWNS MORE
WEALTH THAN THE BOTTOM
125 MILLION AMERICANS.
THAT’S WRONG.
THAT’S IMMORAL.
>> I CAN’T SPEAK FOR IT, ALL I
KNOW IS I HAVE BEEN VERY LUCKY,
MADE A LOT OF MONEY AND I’M
GIVING IT ALL THE WAY TO MAKE
THIS COUNTRY BETTER.
AND A GOOD CHUNK OF IT GOES TO
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY AS WELL.
>> HAVE YOU EARNED TOO MUCH
MONEY?
IS IT AN OBSCENE AMOUNT --
SHOULD YOU HAVE EARNED THAT MUCH
MONEY?
>> YES, I WORKED VERY HARD FOR
IT AND I’M GIVING IT AWAY.
>> Laura: CAN YOU BELIEVE THAT
QUESTION, FIRST OF ALL CUSTOMER
SHOULD YOU HAVE EARNED THAT
MUCH -- BLOOMBERG’S BEST EFFORT
AT DEFENDING CAPITALISM ACTUALLY
CAME LATER IN THE DEBATE WHEN
BERNIE WENT IN FOR THE KILL.
>> MR. BLOOMBERG, IT WASN’T YOU
WHO MADE ALL THAT MONEY.
MAYBE YOUR WORKERS PLAYED SOME
ROLE IN THAT AS WELL.
AND IT’S IMPORTANT THAT WORKERS
HAVE SOME OF THE BENEFIT.
I WANT WORKERS TO BE ABLE TO SIT
ON CORPORATE BOARDS AS WELL SO
THEY HAVE SOME SAY IN WHAT
HAPPENS IN THEIR LIVES.
>> WOULD YOU SUPPORT WHAT
SENATOR SANDERS IS SUPPORTING?
>> ABSOLUTELY NOT.
I CAN’T THINK OF A WAY THAT
WOULD MAKE IT EASIER FOR
DONALD TRUMP TO GET ELECTED THEM
BY LISTENING TO THIS
CONVERSATION.
IT’S RIDICULOUS.
WE ARE NOT GOING TO THROW OUT
CAPITALISM.
WE TRIED THAT, OTHER COUNTRIES
TRIED THAT.
IT WAS CALLED COMMUNISM AND IT
JUST DIDN’T WORK.
>> Laura: WELL, NEITHER DID
YOUR PERFORMANCE, FRANKLY.
IT IS TOO LITTLE, TOO LATE.
BLOOMBERG HAS GONE THROUGH LIFE
THINKING THAT HE WHO PAYS THE
PIPER CALLS THE TUNE.
THAT RICH FOLKS HAVE REAL POWER
IN THE REST OF US, WE HAVE TO DO
WITH THE RICH PEOPLE SAY.
BUT BOTH TRUMP AND BERNIE, THEY
UNDERSTAND POWER BETTER THAN
BLOOMBERG DOES.
THEY KNOW THAT YOU CAN ALSO
ACHIEVE POWER BY HAVING A STRONG
MESSAGE AND TAKING THAT MESSAGE
RIGHT TO THE VOTERS.
BUT FOR YEARS, BLOOMBERG IGNORED
THE MANY SIGNS THAT G.O.P.
VOTERS WERE FED UP WITH THE TYPE
OF PEOPLE WHO RAN OUR PARTY AND
THEY WANTED TO GO IN A MORE
POPULOUS DIRECTION.
AND OF COURSE THE POPULISTS
EVENTUALLY TOOK OVER THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY AND THEN
BLOOMBERG BECAME A DEMOCRAT.
MEANWHILE, THE LEFT HAS SPENT
DECADES TEACHING FOLKS THAT
AMERICA IS AN EVIL COUNTRY, THAT
CAPITALISM IS EVIL, THAT RICH
PEOPLE LIKE BLOOMBERG OR EVEN,
EVEN IF HE GIVES AWAY HIS MONEY
AND THAT WE WILL ALL DIE SOON
DUE TO AND IMMEDIATE, EMERGENCY.
NOW BLOOMBERG FINDS HIMSELF
TRAPPED.
HE ACTUALLY CARES ABOUT HIS
ISSUES, AND HE WANTS TO NOMINATE
A SOCIALIST.
EVEN IF THAT RISKS LOSING IT ALL
TO TRUMP.
IT’S HAPPENING TO BLOOMBERG, IT
SHOULD BE A LESSON TO ANYONE
WHO CARES ABOUT CAPITALISM.
IF THE VOTERS DON’T TRUST THE
FREE MARKET SYSTEM, THEY WILL
TRY TO ABOLISH IT AND CAMPAIGNS
AND A LOT OF MONEY THAT YOU
SPENT ON CONSULTANTS WON’T BE
SUFFICIENT TO CHANGE THEIR
MINDS.
LAST NIGHT’S DEBATE SHOWED THAT
TRUMP IS THE LAST BEST HOPE FOR
CAPITALISM, BECAUSE HE SUPPORTS
A MARKET SYSTEM BUT ALSO
UNDERSTANDS THE IMPORTANCE OF
MAKING SURE THAT AMERICAN
WORKERS BENEFIT FROM THAT SYSTEM
SYSTEM.
BUT IT’S TOO LATE FOR SOMEONE
LIKE BLOOMBERG TO PARACHUTE IN
AND TELL EVERYONE SIT DOWN AND